[Music]
in nice try news nice tie by the Hat
submitted by King Joe 2020
oh [ __ ] King that president please vote
for me I said he's moving to Vietnam oh
there's no king and and may is claiming
he completed his life sentence because
he briefly died that's funny if I died
in jail then I came back that's for sure
what I'm fighting for so his name is
Benjamin he is a convicted murderer who
collapsed in his prison cell in 2015
they had two doctors had to restart his
heart five times today like five life
sentences according to him yeah I was
trying to do and so he thought he's 66
by the way so he ended up recovering
back at the Iowa State Penitentiary so
he ended up filing a legal appeal
because he said that since he died he
technically served his life sentence
also they they went against his wishes
of do not resuscitate oh he did want to
just leave me alone
he took his case and they denied it and
then he went again and they also denied
it and they said like listen it's either
you're alive
and you serve or you're completely dead
and the the [ __ ] this entire case is
able to appeal at first place so anyway
he's been behind bars since 1996 because
he was charged after a 39 year old body
was found that was bludgeoned and so it
was near use found near an abandoned
trailer in rural Iowa and so they're
saying here that he had back then he was
43 years old he had plotted with the
victims girlfriend before clubbing the
man to death with the wooden handle of a
pick a cold fault so the jury found him
guilty of first-degree murder and in
1997 he was sentenced to life without
parole
that's like a crazy I guess you did
serve his life though mm-hmm is that why
they like sometimes say like three life
sentences mm-hmm is that why or I never
understood I think this
like excessive like just to make a point
but yeah the principle because like each
charge was like murder assault like it
was like bad like they were each really
bad I think it's the court its way of
doing a middle finger so this three life
centers at pow-pow your extra never get
out yeah I bought he'd they should have
given him a couple em yeah cuz they do I
mean he would have served three right
because he died five times does he get
out no like I said they denied it and
then so they I don't know if he's gonna
try to appeal it to a higher I way might
be the third time I would I'd like give
me the [ __ ] out of here I died already
he's 65 and he's like well [ __ ] I kill
you my last five years here
[ __ ] him he took a life he shouldn't
think that way but I [ __ ] die already
so back when he when his heart failed
maybe go write a children's book he was
hit with severe septic poisoning because
he had developed kidney stones that were
so large it caused him to urinate
internally so Monster energy drinks in
there too so you Steve is like I knew it
was genetic I knew you can't he began
orgy drinks in jail yeah so he fell
unconscious and he was rushed to the
hospital hospital where doctors brought
him back to life by administering
epinephrine na CPR there in IV I would
never kiss at me me too he is claiming
that but what if it was lady jail no I
still wouldn't Yeah right
maybe that is negligent to like leave
someone suffering with kidney stones
like that long cuz well that's not even
his case his case is that he's being
held in prison illegally Oh bro he had
already died he his sentence ended when
he died
and he said he didn't want to be
resuscitated but they did recessed yeah
he has a deep you fight that would
bother me I wanted to die in [ __ ] could
he choose to like get put on death row
or something alright
I don't know who could choose that
because how many inmates we just do it
yeah I've always life in prison why
don't I do it it's more expensive to
kill someone than to actually just keep
them alive until they died it is yeah I
don't know why I'm I ran her name oh you
don't know but I think it's maybe the
drugs or like I do all this yeah well I
think that if I was a lifer I'd look for
the prison with the best food so it's
like I was listened to
like it over there yeah the prison yelp
review there is a movie and then you go
okay can you transfer me to this Jail
ten times more expensive to kill them
than to keep them alive why sure I don't
buy it they're just keeping them alive
getting a chance they keep it alive at
the bare minimum circumstances you know
but they get money for each inmate
that's yeah well how come they cost more
to house death row inmate Oh to house
them maybe that's why Oh cuz death rules
like kind of fancy I'm compared to the
general population yeah I don't think I
don't know why I just killing them is
cheaper than taking care of them that
doesn't make any sense yeah very quickly
we do have a pretty crazy jaw justice
system they'll compare to the rest of
the world crazy isn't bad or good I
think it's good I think we have a man I
don't have nothing to compare it to well
people yeah so people are like I know we
can do better we can always do better
but I think it's generally good yeah
after spending an estimated 4.2 million
dollars for each death sentence the
state has executed no one since 1963
I heard that Scandinavian jails are like
European some some European jails are
like really [ __ ] good though like
they they feel like you just living in
the park see the Aesop Rock e9y what was
it like it was good on the surface but
remember they were saying [ __ ] like it's
actually really bad and stuff yeah well
prisons bad haha it was not as worse as
bad as here yeah they were saying like
it's not as what we thought it would be
but the prison there looked like man he
looked better than some backpacker ass
like hostel but it's not just because he
was famous or is that for general
population I think it's kind of like
this stereotype that general population
jail there it looks like an apartment
complex like it just looks like normal
living and it's like nice and they have
all this [ __ ] to actually try to
rehabilitate criminals out there yeah I
wonder if there's but rape culture and
all the jails all over the world where
it's only here I think men get horny and
all over the world
and they [ __ ] what they can true over
that's her like I knew I didn't know but
I just fold it it's like some jails
aren't like so for example like when you
think of North Korean jails or whatever
like like political prisoner poor jails
and stuff right I don't think the same
gangrened jails that we have I think
like just broke people or people that's
been through hard [ __ ] times it's I
think that's a different jail system
versus our jails it's like gangs and
[ __ ] yeah but you don't think that every
jail forms like a community like you
have nothing else to do you know that's
why I like gay for the stay is the thing
you know like in women's prisons like
women form relationships within each
other and they like you unite to whoever
you relate to you know that's why
there's like the Mexicans and the whites
and the blacks or whatever but here
there's just so many different like
kinds of people that's why we group each
other in those ways yeah so this is
Benjamin the guy who tried to get out
being in jail how does he look like a
freakin like old-school Star Trek
character he looks like a vital Asian
man no it looks Asian I guess yeah I
can't no bye oh yeah he looks like he
smells through in the bed
oh yeah only cause he's a bad guy oh no
he doesn't see like he sees the Sun oh
yeah weird I don't see it definitely
it's a deadly agent forehead looks like
usually I think more flattering I could
tell because Casey's forehead looks like
comparing him to that guy this guy's
trying to give him props for creative
I'll give it to him he's trying he's
gotta be better to do do you think he
was so commit crimes if you got out who
knows man who knows how to mint it into
a statistics show people like it's not a
super high chance of going back he's
already like this conniving to be like
what well I died you know like so I feel
like you he still has that inline set of
like how do I get out of this thing
there
that according to court records hospital
staffers made the decision to
resuscitate him after talking to his
brother but his brother says like he
only consented to giving him medicine to
ease his pain not necessarily to
resuscitate him so I don't know have you
all seen um I think it's called locked
up abroad yeah it's [ __ ] crazy huh
so it's stories about like people that
live in America or like UK or whatever
and then they get locked up in like
South America Southeast Asia or like
these other countries right and it's
usually because like they were suckered
in as trafficking drugs or whatever
reason and then like they don't realize
how crazy the drug laws are like there's
this one episode where this girl was
like I guess she was moving heroin from
Thailand or whatever and when she went
into Thai jail she was she has all these
stories of getting jumped by the girl
there and all this [ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah
like they sleep like just all in one big
room on the floor
Netflix no I forgot where I saw it this
was it was on TV like it was like a
series but there's all these stories of
people who had to do time overseas and
it's no joke out there like there's like
South American jails were like it's
basically like you go in and there's
really no jailers or anything it's all
just the jail people running it like the
criminals running it all and they're
just caged up and then like the trucks
come in like they just give them food
and then they just have to figure out
how to do that on their own fact they
get locked up abroad I'll go to the
Filipino jail why they still learn how
to dance sing and dance is fun yeah they
have like this choreographed dance show
that they pull off for tourists and it
went viral on YouTube like years ago I
think I I know what you're talking about
yeah yeah that looks like a fun line but
it gives you something to do you know
you create something like the pilot this
is the violence dropped a lot of the
crimes dropped with in jail because it
gave them something to do and like they
don't want their dance privileges taken
away so they actually really look
forward to you Cory
before that comes in never when the
choreographers come in like they
actually really liked so the
choreographers they're not even scared
of walking through yeah everyone loves
them so much and then you'll see it was
funny as a there's all these like bald
Filipino dudes with like tattoos all
over the place and they're clowning on
that one homey that has no rhythm and
you can't [ __ ] like it I like they
just all turn into like little kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]